i'm here with danny theo and ross
matthews and we're talking all things
thrifty for thrifty week and we wanted
to share some amazing tips that we've
learned over the years
to keep yourself thrifty and thriving
none of us know each other's tips so
we're going to surprise each other
i can't wait to hear about yours and i
cannot wait to do mine all right
i know i'm like a greyhound at the gate
i am so ready for this all right share
your tip okay
i saw this in a hotel lobby so i'm
totally stealing it but i was obsessed
with it okay you know you've seen at the
thrift store like paintings that are
kind of dated or like above grandma's
couch it's like not cute well
what if you took some paint some tape
and reimagined these paintings to be
like this
right
so you just put a piece of tape here for
a
clean seam and then you can get little
cans of paint you know at the hardware
store i know it's like sample cam sample
for like a couple dollars yeah right and
so then you can just experiment and the
trick here is to paint the frame too
and then it reimagines grandma's old art
piece and you can go big look what i
have
come with me look
i love a reveal so this was over some
ugly couch one day and now look at it
boom
for just a couple dollars
i mean
i am impressed i really really really
like this
[Applause]
i
okay
the mixed media like genre play really
impressive ross thanks barrymore oh
oh gosh all right well all right i was
feeling really confident about mine but
i don't know um okay
here is my thrifty tip now
you can go to a facialist they're gonna
charge you a whole bunch of money and
let's face it i don't have the time and
like recently i just broke out so this
is a perfect example um now
what
facialists use is this little thing
called a lancer you can buy them at any
drugstore and you get a hundred for
eight dollars and trust me they will
last you a few years also remember when
you are done with it you want to throw
it away these are one time use only
that's why so many come in a pack so
what you want to do is you want to take
the little thing and you want to go over
the top of the pimple do not push
inwards you want to lift it and almost
break the seal very gently so that when
you press gently you get an extraction
then
i like to put ice on it
to get the swelling down real fast
and then
you want to take any standard redness
removing eye drop
which takes the red out of your eyes it
also takes the red broken blood vessels
which are the same thing
on your skin and makes it more even
toned and paler so this is a one two
three step that literally you would save
a lot of money by going to a facialist
and it's just a nice simple inexpensive
at-home treatment this has been such a
game-changer in my life what a what a
segue to this one
um
because i'm going to show you how to
make a pinata
[Applause]
well
it's all bursting something that's true
so
i'm popping at the end of the day so
this is called upcycling and we're gonna
take some old cardboard boxes cereal
boxes you just guys are getting a dinner
box from sunbasket you can upcycle that
cardboard box that comes in
and you can make your own pinata now
guys it's so simple
you need a big bowl we're gonna make
these circular ones right here you open
the box you trace the bowl with the
pencil all the way around like this and
you just cut it out with a pair of
scissors
and what you end up with are two circles
just like this okay so this is your
pinata on the outside and then the extra
material you make these little strips
to go all the way around so it becomes
three dimensional you tape it all
together doesn't matter how pretty it
looks because you just want it to come
together just like this with regular
whatever tape you have it doesn't
because you're going to cover it up
anyway
and then the secret to make it look like
this
is you take double stick tape can you
see this it's been striped on yeah like
this all the way you don't have to glue
it or do anything you take your little
strips
you just
[Music]
she won't
and maybe that's why we have breakouts
[Applause]
we're gonna fill up you can also fill it
up with gift cards you can do anything
you want on the inside you know the
pinata has been around for over 700
years i love pinata the ross um you're
the tallest one here could you help me
hang this i certainly can oh god okay
oh oh look at that drew
go for it you want me to yes okay
watch out
and oh
[Applause]
and yet that's the whole point i love
these tips i feel like i'm walking away
with good solid
diversified information i'm i love this
yeah i thought yours really popped
okay um thank you danny ceo so much and
rozzy rest matthew
[Applause]
[Music]